let's go next to
charlie from bayfield colorado now
charlie is bayfield
one of the blue parts of colorado or one
of the red parts
extremely red okay gotcha all right
we'll go ahead
hey man so
i had a had a little commentary i wanted
to make
um
if you would play along for a second
okay
can you
spell the word
or can you say the word s-a-u-s-e
s-a-u-s-e
[Music]
or c-e my bad c-e oh that's uh sauce
right okay what about the word
a-u-r-a
that is aura
aura okay interesting
i'm just i'm just kind of weirded out
about how you always mispronounce vosh's
name after he told you what it is
oh it's just a joke it's just an ongoing
joke that's all it is
i think he says pac-man as well or
something like that it's just a joke
is it not pac-man it's pac-man not
pac-man
oh okay yeah
oh funny so just a little back and forth
between you guys yeah yeah it's just a
joke
oh hey i was just i was so i was i was
upset because i was just i was hoping it
wasn't some giga cringe on your part so
no no no we have a strict no giga cringe
policy on this show
okay okay okay i believe it i believe
that well which is why i'm gonna have to
which is why i'm gonna have to let you
go
[Laughter]
okay and charlie bailed all right wow
uh clip it that's quite quite a phone
call okay let's continue here um let's
go next to miles from bay city michigan
hello mr backman can you hear me just
barely miles i'm going to crank you up
as loud as i can
how about now sir it's marginally better
uh
one and more comment on observations
i've been seeing
you know since i've been working back in
the office
i mean i've been kind of appalled by the
amount of people that are hanging flags
or having decorations that are
you know having profanities like f-bomb
joe biden and it's just like
really
i know it's like very it's like a
continued coarsening of the discourse i
saw a video earlier today
of a guy just walking through a retail
store with an f biden flag and it's less
about like i don't care you know i don't
care about the profanity
but
these are these are what i call asbs
these are attention seeking behaviors
and very often there's like something
going on emotionally for the people that
do it because f biden
you know this is not i feel really
strongly about abortion and i'm against
it right i would disagree with you but
at least it's sort of like substantive
at least
ostensibly
but
f biden it's just an attention seeking
behavior and
i almost sometimes wonder whether it's
better not to give it any attention not
to even acknowledge it
i mean i can definitely understand that
aspect but
i don't know maybe it's just like
growing up as a kid you know i don't
recall seeing anything of this sort to
where it's just like i grew up in a
christian household you know even saying
you know any even lesser swear word was
it very punishable so the fact that you
know there are kids out there today that
kind of see this stuff and i don't know
if kids are like me when i was growing
up i'd see something and i'd repeat it
so it's just a matter of oh great
yeah i mean i don't have i don't have
that hang up like i don't really worry
about kids seeing profanity you know in
many countries tv has profanity and it's
just like no big deal so for me it's
less about that it's just that the
discourse is getting stupider and
stupider and
people don't understand the difference
between what kind of a statement is a
factual statement and what kind of a
statement is a statement of opinion
and we're really just losing our ability
to even disagree
because
people misunderstand what it even means
to have an opinion disagreement versus
to be unable to establish the facts of
something so for me it's more of like a
structural problem
ah very understandable yeah
well i appreciate your time so but let
me ask you so when you see the f biden
flags that co-workers have do you do you
acknowledge it or mention it in any way
or just ignore it uh no thankfully none
of my co-workers do it's just i got
quite a commute to the office so oh
it's more along the lines of you know as
i'm going to work and passing through i
gotcha
stuff like that and it's
to me it's still just a little eyebrow
raising again it's just the amount of
profanities and it's just like come on
think of
i don't know
children thing is an important part it
sounds like
exactly i'm
not
it's not it's not a paid job it's part
of a hobby but i i help teach martial
arts and you know i have a you know soft
spot for kids you know i want to make
sure i teach them good things and stuff
like that outside of martial arts so
at that point when i see that stuff i'm
like i guess they don't care about kids
seeing that kind of stuff i mean i've
seen one where it's the same kind of fun
except it says impeach bite and i'm like
thank you at least you have the decency
to not use profanities
at least that's ostensibly a political
statement yeah all right my friend well
i appreciate the perspective thank you
all right thank you sir all right let's
take a quick pause if you're holding on
to talk to me and you continue to want
to talk to me if you've not been
dissuaded yet just hang on because we're
going right back to the phones
momentarily